Hamilton fans have long loved the stage production,
but the film version on Disney Plus brings
whole new meaning to key moments in the story.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing 11 surprising and
often satisfying ways the Hamilton movie enhances
or changes our experience of the musical.
In other words, I'm explaining why it matters
who films, who edits, who directs your story.
Just before we begin, many thanks to the sponsor
of this video, Full Sail University.
One of the nine cameras used to film the show
by cinematographer Declan Quinn was set up
to capture overhead shots of the stage.
Because that angle can be rather disorienting
for viewers, it's used sparingly during the
final movie.
But one of the moments where it does make
an appearance is during Satisfied.
It's a fleeting shot from above but it heightens
our understanding of Angelica's distress
and also gives us a bird's-eye-view of the
clever lighting design where the lights converge
on Angelica as the words "drowning, drowning,
rewind" echo around the stage.
All of that emphasises the sense of the world
closing in on Angelica and being at the centre
of a figurative storm, an explosion of emotions.
The film's quick overhead angle therefore
adds to the disorienting experience of the
whole song and its choreography as the lyrics
and dance moves rewind to earlier in the show.
As Hamilton's film editor Jonah Moran told
The Art of the Cut podcast,
that view is something people never see in
the live stage show, even in the mezzanine
you still "don't really get that perspective".
There were lots of comments about Laurens
and Hamilton on my previous videos.
Huge thanks to everyone for those.
And many of you saw the often-lingering looks
exchanged between them as the show pointing
to their being more than just close friends.
"Laurens, I like you a lot"
Indeed, in the film, the way the camera often
goes in for close-ups of the two of them seems
to highlight that, or at the very least leave
it open for interpretation.
There are many examples of this in the first
act, including Stay Alive where the camera
moves in when Laurens tells Hamilton he'll
fight Charles Lee,
then the camera goes in even closer, lingering
on Laurens' reaction to Hamilton's reply.
The camera pushes in as well during the Story
of Tonight, which is also poignant for being
one of several ways the show foreshadows both
Laurens' death
and the moment Hamilton discovers this in
Tomorrow There'll Be More of Us, which again
includes an extended moment between the two
men.
In real life, Hamilton wrote many affectionate
letters to Laurens, including one where he
says,
"I wish, my dear Laurens, it might be in my
power, by action rather than words, to convince
you that I love you."
Historians tend to say they can't be definitive
whether the two were lovers.
Ron Chernow, who wrote the biography which
inspired Lin-Manuel Miranda's musical, calls
their relationship
"the most intimate friendship of Hamilton's
life",
adding that "at the very least, we can say
that" Hamilton had "something like an adolescent
crush on his friend".
And according to Chernow, after Laurens died,
Hamilton "never again revealed his interior
life to another man as he had to Laurens",
"he shut off some compartment of his emotions
and never reopened it".
Lin-Manuel Miranda told EW that "when you
watch this movie, you have a house seat that
never existed",
and he's absolutely right as one of the cameras
had a view towards the audience thanks to
a hole cut into the back of the set!
And it's from that entirely fresh perspective
that we first meet King George, as he strides
past us, emerging from the shadows to be bathed
in red light.
That shot from behind really adds to the drama
of the King's entrance, nicely building up
to his first moment in the spotlight.
During live performances, you might only spot
how dripping with madness King George is if
you're near enough to the stage;
but now that the film gives us all the best
and same seat in the house, as the Hamilton
team put it,
no one can miss just how drenched in sarcasm
and saliva Jonathan Groff's performance gets.
Yes, thanks to the filmmakers going right
in for lots of close-ups, everyone can now
appreciate Groffsauce, as Miranda nicknamed
him, as he enunciates and projects his way
around the stage!
And Groff himself told Variety that he's always
been quite the spitter when it comes to performing
live.
"Hurricane" takes us inside Hamilton's head
and reveals his thinking behind making his
affair with Maria Reynolds public.
As he reflects on his life, the show's lighting
and choreography put him in the eye of a storm,
still at first, then with people from his
past and present, including his enemies, friends,
lover, and mother spinning around him,
in a call-back to the literal hurricane that
ultimately led him to leave his hometown for
America.
The show's staging and story are underscored
by the film's camerawork.
For director Thomas Kail, using a Steadicam
to film this scene meant they were able to
use the lens to
"create a closeness to Hamilton's decision"
"by really being up close with Lin-Manuel
Miranda."
As Kail told EW, "There's a way that the Steadicam
floats which feels a little out of time.
So, it felt like a chance to be with Hamilton
in the midst of this stillness before the
explosion.
And that creates a sense of anticipation for
what's about to come."
Given the potentially disorienting effect
of overhead shots, it's totally fitting that
they pop up again during The Reynolds Pamphlet
where we see the effects of Hamilton's document
about his extra-marital affair going public.
The scene on stage is already a crazy one,
with several of the main cast and the ensemble
dancing around,
throwing leaflets into the air, and generally
revelling in Hamilton's self-inflicted downfall.
For me, the overhead shot of Hamilton in the
middle of this chaos
adds to the scene's sense of "deliriousness",
smug "celebration", "schadenfreude", and general
"feeling that the world is crashing" down
around him, to use Miranda's words.
The overhead shot highlights the fact that,
despite being surrounded by people, he's very
much alone.
It does this by giving us a quick but clear
view of him as a lone figure in the centre
of the action,
being circled and taunted by a gleeful Jefferson
and King George, while Madison tosses his
pamphlets up into the camera,
and all the while they sing "Never gon' be
president now".
On top of that, the aerial shot also reveals
one of the male dancers writhing around on
the floor,
seemingly mocking the kind of move that got
Hamilton in this trouble in the first place.
And all of that together dials up the wild
nature of the scene.
Another way the film enhances the story is
using close-ups to reveal different perspectives
by focusing on the actors' performances.
During Helpless, just after Alexander and
Eliza first meet, we see Angelica's reaction
from the side,
"I'll leave you to it",
just for a second before the camera moves
to her sister, because this song is Eliza's
point of view.
However, when we get to Satisfied, the story
gives us a different viewpoint on that evening,
and the film mirrors the way the narrative
refocuses by literally re-framing the situation
so that now we clearly see the reaction on
Angelica's face in that moment,
as this time the camera pushes in on her.
"I'll leave you to it."
Overall, this whole number, and the way it's
shot and edited in the film, continues to
build the show's major theme that history
is different depending on who tells it.
Of course, Satisfied is really emotional,
but much of it is performed at a break-neck
pace,
to underline both Angelica's brilliance and
her distress, and the stage itself is frequently
full of activity during the song.
To reflect that lyrical speed and action on
the stage, and "because Renée Elise Goldsberry's
so expressive",
editor Jonah Moran chose to use lots of quick-cut
close-ups so that
"you see that emotion and it flies right at
you, just like the song is flying at you."
By the way, fun fact, director Thomas Kail
told Screenrant that the way Satisfied goes
"into the mind and the heart of Angelica Schuyler"
was heavily influenced by the scene in Pixar's
Ratatouille where the "critic takes a bite
of the food.
And in that moment, you go into his eye, and
you go back to see his childhood [...],
and then he has this visceral and emotional
connection to the food."
When a Hamilfan asked Renée Elise Goldsberry
on twitter about her favourite hairstyle in
the show, we got a little insight into another
thing that changed for the movie.
Angelica has several different looks in the
musical, and normally Goldsberry's favourite
is the high bun she wears towards the end,
however, for the filmed version, the actress
chose to change up her early look.
So, instead of wearing a wig as she does on
stage for the first part of the story, she
went with her own hair with some added volume
in the back, as she didn't want her usual
lace-front wig on screen.
As I mentioned in my "Hamilton Things You
Missed" video, the lyrics run at a breath-takingly
fast-and-furious speed,
so having access to captions right there on
the screen where it happens is great both
for those with hearing loss as well as everyone
else.
Even if you already know every line of the
show off by heart, seeing the words pop up
on screen means,
for example, you can now easily see how specific
lyrics are tied to specific dance moves, gestures
and facial expressions.
And that can be rather revealing because as
choreographer Andy Blankenbuehler has said,
every movement on stage "furthers the story
in some way".
And I talk more about that in my video on
the show's Secret Character.
Also, in a production where the lyrics are
jam-packed with multiple meanings, historical
references, hat-tips to different musical
genres, witty retorts, and word-play,
being able to read each and every line on
screen makes it easier to notice more of those
amazing details.
Of course, some but not all theatre productions
have surtitles,
but having captions right in front of you
during the film means you don't have to look
to the side or crick your neck to read what's
being said, as can be the case in the theatre.
Speaking of lyrics, if you've seen the show
live or listened to the soundtrack, you'll
likely notice that a couple of moments are
censored for language in the film on Disney
Plus.
That was to avoid getting an R rating, instead
of the PG-13 rating the film ended up with.
First of all, in the song "Yorktown", the
f-bomb is muted during Hercules Mulligan's
line
"When you knock me down, I get the **** back
up again!".
Then in the second act during "Washington
On Your Side", Jefferson and Madison's expletive
in the line
"Southern mother**** Democratic-Republicans"
is overlayed with sound, which Miranda called
a "record scratch", to erase it.
The change means the film is accessible to
a wider audience than it would have been otherwise,
and, as Miranda told fans on twitter, "You
can sing whatever you like at home, even sync
up the album!"
And if you feel inspired to learn the kind
of skills the Hamilton filmmakers used to
make their amazing movie,
check out Full Sail University whose graduate
students have landed jobs on award-winning
movies and TV shows including Joker, Toy Story
4, Avengers: Endgame, and Game of Thrones.
Full Sail's Film Bachelor's degree program
immerses you in the world of filmmaking from
every angle.
You'll gain practical experience while learning
what it's like to work on a film from start
to finish, giving you a feel for the role
each crew member plays in a production.
And the Digital Cinematography online degree
program merges the artistic concepts of traditional
filmmaking
with the technical tools used in everything
from documentary filmmaking to commercial
production and web video.
These degrees are offered in an accelerated
format to get you into the field faster.
If you want to find out more about these film
programs and how to get started, visit FullSail.edu/FlicksAndTheCity
to learn more.
That's FullSail.edu/FlicksAndTheCity.
So, what moments stood out for you in the
film and did you notice any changes?
Let me know in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, don't forget to subscribe
and leave a thumbs-up.
To learn more about all the other amazing
details in the musical and how the show changed
history, tap left for my full Hamilton playlist.
Or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!